الى مراسلتنا في رام الله جيفارا البديري
اذا بنغير اقتحم المسجد الاقصى ليست المره
الاولى التي يكون فيها هذا الوزير مثيرا
للجدل
بالفعل زين هذه هي المره الثانيه وفق بيان
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الذي يقتحم فيها
المسجد الاقصى المبارك بمنصبه
كوزير للامن القومي
الاسرائيلي عمليه الاقتحام كانت صباح هذا
اليوم تقريبا في تمام السابعه والنصف
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهو التوقيت المحدده
لدخول غير المسلمين الى المسجد الاقصى
المبارك وهي الفتره الصباحيه بالطبع دخل
بنك فير بحمايه امنيه مشدده جدا الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه في بيانها اكدت بعد ان دانت
هذه العمليه بان
هذا اعتداء سافر له تداعيات خطيره وفقا
ايضا الناطق باسم الرئاسه نبيل ابو ردين
الذي اضاف بان محاولات
وامثالهم من
فينا لن يغير الوضع القائم القانوني
والتاريخي في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
اقتحم المسجد في ساعه مبكره كاللصوص هكذا
وصف
الناطق باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه دخول
بنكفير الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك كاللصوص
وان ذلك لن يفلح في تغيير الواقع ولن يفرض
سياده اسرائيل عليه ايضا في بيان
وادانا ايضا من وزاره الاوقاف
والشؤون الدينيه الفلسطينيه اكد الوزير
الهباش بان ذلك اعتداء وتدنيس لمكان ديني
هو خالص
للمسلمين ليس لغيرهم اي احقيه في ممارسه
العباده داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك واكدت
الوزاره في بيان اصدرته ودانت فيه اقتحام
المسجد الاقصى
مبارك انا ما تقوم به الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المتطرفه هي جريمه نقرا واعتداء على
المقدسات واماكن العباده الاسلاميه وطالبه
البيان المجتمع الدولي الى وضع حد لحكومه
اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل وتماديها حيث
ان هذه الانتهاكات للمسجد الاقصى تاخذ كما
قالت الوزاره منحى تصاعديا تحت ولايه
تحالف اليمين
المتطرف بالطبع ايضا كان البيانات منذ
ساعات الصباح وفوره نشر النبا ونشر اصلا
هو من نشر هذه الصور لاقتحامه للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك حاله من
السنكار الكامل الادانه عدم المطالبه فقط
بان يقتصر الامر على الادانات والشجبه
والاستنكار بل ان يكون هناك يعني فعلي رغم
انه لم يحدث اي مواجهات في داخل المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وذلك لانه بالفعل دخل بين
جفير دون علم من احد خاصه ايضا من دائره
الاوقاف الاسلاميه التي هي اصلا من تشرف
على المسجد الاقصى المبارك وكونه معروف
فان الاردن تحديدا هي صاحبه الوصايه على
المقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه وعلى راسها
المسجد الاقصى المباركيه ادانت الرفضت
ويبدو ان هناك ايضا الان يعني جدال واسع
بين الاردن واسرائيل نذكر هنا فقط زين
وسهام ان هناك قبل يومين وتحديدا
ظهر يوم الخميس كانت التحضيرات لما تعرف
بالمسيره
للذكرى السادسه والخمسين لاحتلال الشطر
الشرقي من مدينه القدس المحتله وضمها
للقدس كعاصمه موحده لاسرائيل كان الوضع
متوتر جدا ولاول مره نرى
الذي دعا الى محو بلده حواره قبل اشهر
وعدد اخر من النواب المتطرفين في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي شاركوا وسط غمره وسط احتفالات
بهذه المسيره التي كان يمكن ان تفجر الوضع
برمته
يعني هو اصلا من اوجد فكره قبل ان يصبح
وزير في هذه الحكومه فكره اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى المبارك دخل وقتحم المسجد كثير من
المرات في الفتره الصباحيه كانت تحدث بعد
ذلك مواجهات لكن هذه هي المره الثانيه
التي يقتحم فيها المسجد الاقصى المبارك
كوزير في حكومه اسرائيليه يفترض ان لها
علاقات سواء علاقات تطبيع او علاقات سلام
ولكن ايضا مع الاردن
وتاكيد الاردن تاكيد العرب تاكيد المجتمع
الدولي ان المسجد الاقصى المبارك هو
للمسلمين وحدهم فقط وهم اصحاب الوصايه
ولكن واضح ان اسرائيل تحاول تثبيت فكره ان
الحائط الغربي الذي تسميه اسرائيل بحائط
المبكى يسميه الفلسطينيون والعرب بحائط
البراق وايضا النقطه التي يمكن ان تشعل
الامور برمتها
دخل المسجد واقتحمه لكن في الوقت المخصص
لدخول غير المسلمين ما هي الاجراءات
المتبعه
لدخول غير المسلمين للمسجد
بحيث لا يعتبر اقتحاما لا يعتبر دخول
المسجد في هذا الوقت اقتحاما
هكذا يسمى ستاتيكو ما بين الاردن والسلطه
بعد ذلك السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل يخصص
فترتين لغير المسلمين بدخول المسجد الاقصى
المبارك الفتره الصباحيه من السابعه
السابعه والنصف بتوقيت القدس المحتله الى
الحاديه عشره وايضا بعد صلاه الظهر في
المسجد تكون هناك عاده اجراءات مشدده
لحمايه
المستوطنين وفقا ادعاءات شرطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولكن عندما يدخل نائب في
الكنيست او حتى الان عندما نرى وزير
معناها اجراءات امنيه مشدده تنتشر قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في كل انحاء وباحات
المسجد الاقصى المبارك في محيطه وايضا في
محيط البلده القديمه
وغير الانتشار المكثف يكون هناك
قوات تسير مع هؤلاء
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك البعض يتساءل لماذا
يقال مقتحمين ان لم يكن ان كان اصلا ذلك
يتم وفق الاتفاق لان هؤلاء عاده ما يقومون
بطقوس تلموديه وصلوات مهما كان الوقت حتى
ان لم يكن بفتره اعياد
لليهود وذروه هذه الاقتحامات تكون تحديدا
في شهر رمضان المبارك وهو ما يشعل الوضع
الميداني برمته ولكن الدخول يكون ايضا
بمنع المصلين الفلسطينيين من التواجد في
الساحات يتم ابعادهم احيانا الاعتداء
بالضرب احيانا اغلاق المصلى القبلي واجبار
الفلسطينيين والمصلين المسلمين على الدخول
الى داخل المسجد القبلي واغلاق الابواب
الاقفال او حتى دخولهم الى المصلى
المرواني وايضا مسجد قبه الصخره اذا يكون
هناك استفزاز للفلسطينيين من التنقل بحريه
ولكن دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه طوال الوقت
سر انها من هي المخوله بالسماح بدخول اي
احد الى داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك بمعنى
ان تم الشك بان هذا الذي يدخل الى المسجد
او امراه او رجل ليس عربي او مسلم فلا
يمكن الدخول ولكن قوات الاحتلال لا تؤمن
بذلك لا تقوم بذلك على الارض بل حتى في
محاوله للتخفيف من وطاهه هذا الوضع تقوم
بادخال المقتحمين والسماح لهم بالدخول في
الفتره الصباحيه ولكن هذه الزياره ايضا
يعني تنعكس لما حدث بعد ذلك بحوالي الساعه
ان تقوم الحكومه الاسرائيليه بعقد جلستها
الاسبوعيه في داخل احد
الانفاق التي تم حفره اسفل المسجد الاقصى
المبارك من الجهه الغربيه وهو كما ذكرنا
من
حائط البراق ايضا هو بنظر الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه
والوزارات المعنيه هو قمه الاستفزاز يعني
وكان بنظر الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ووفقه
بيانيا هو ليس فقط اعتداء سافر وتدنيس
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك ولكن هو رساله
لتصعيد الوضع الميداني برمته يعني ما لبثت
الحرب على غزه ان تضع اوزارها العمليات
العسكريه متواصله في الضفه الغربيه تحديدا
في الشمال عند تحديدا في نابلس واجنين
ولكن الان ينظر بخطوره شديده جدا لعقد هذه
الجلسه جلسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه برئاسه
نتنياهو في داخل احد هذه الانفاق بالطبع
هذه الانفاق كان هناك طوال الوقت تحذير من
الاستمرار بحفرها لانها تهدد اساسات
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وكما هو معلوم فان
المتطرفين اليهود
مشددين العنصريين والذين يوصفون الان
بالفاشيين هم يريدون التهديد هذه الاساسات
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك لاقامه ما يوصف
بالهيكل المزعوم اذا كل الاجراءات تتسارع
على الارض وبعض المراقبين يرون ان عدم
اتخاذ اي خطوات فعليه سواء فلسطينيه رسميه
دوليه عربيه بشكل فاعل وليس فقط
الادانه عبر البيانات والاستنكار ولكن ان
يكون هناك افعال فعليه على الارض لن يتغير
هذا الوا